as a slides of loading there there is no
topic that should occupy your minds more
as you build your company then bring it
on the team that's going to make your
company successful as you move forward
Hajin amin from triple byte YC alumnus
are going to talk about building in
today's day and age perhaps the key
portion of that team the engineering
team so please welcome harsh you're
starting yeah harsh alright thanks for
having us everyone
so I'm Hodge I'm one of the cofounders
of trip I along with Arman previously I
used to be a partner at Y Combinator and
part of the inspiration of sighing
triple buy it was noticing how after
graduating y Combinator
and raising the first investment around
everyone's number one problem was hiring
and specifically hiring engineers
because the hardest hiring challenge so
three working on to a bite which is a
hiring marketplace that's used by
engineers to find new places to work
Armen and I have gathered lots of data
on what works well when it comes to
hiring engineers
I've personally focused a lot on
spending time with companies helping
them think through their strategies for
finding engineers and obviously getting
the most out of triple buy it and Arman
spent a lot of time thinking through the
details of how do you evaluate an
engineer how to evaluate the engineering
skill and answer the question of are
they a good engineer or not so we're
going to share that and sort of have a
divide and conquer strategy going on
here the four main topics we're going to
cover are where to look for engineers
and when you should start thinking about
using recruiters and that's what I'm
going to start with then we'll talk
about evaluating technical skills which
are Mons gonna cover and then I'll
finish up by talking through the process
of making offers and closing which is
getting people to actually join your
team but before we start on any of that
I want to just issue a warning and make
sure you're well prepared for the fact
that hiring really well and truly sucks
it's like incredibly painful process
because for many reasons which I'll
describe in detail the first is it takes
a lot of time like it takes a lot of
time just to convince someone good to
eat
and have a conversation with you and as
a founder as you know time is a very
scarce resource there's bugs to fix
there's sales customers to close various
things going on and hiring will never
feel like it's your top most urgent
priority and it's very easy to
procrastinate and push it back but if
you do that for too long you won't scale
and you won't grow your startup and
someone else will come along do that and
take the market to hiring involves a lot
of repetitive work so actually as Tyler
was giving his presentation I was
talking to Jeff about this back there
there's a lot of similarities between
sales and hiring and actually there's a
lot of similarities between sales and
hiring and fundraising and buy lots of
things that you do as a start-up founder
large part of it is effectively selling
all of the time and selling as Tyler
pointed out involves a lot of repetitive
work this so hiring will involve lots of
messaging and revolve taking lots of
coffee meetings lots of phone calls lots
of interviews and most of those will
result in the dead end and be a complete
waste of your time but you have to keep
going and finally you will get your
heart broken you will inevitably end up
getting rejected by people you really
wanted to hire who would have been the
perfect fit to help you hit your growth
goals but it turns out they were never
really that serious about leaving their
comfortable job at a big company to join
your exciting but risky startup so be
prepared for all of this and as you're
thinking through building a hiring
process I encourage you to think about
this as a funnel that you're creating
that has three parts to it the top of
the funnel is sourcing and that's
finding people who could be good fit the
second is screening that's answering the
question of do you want to hire this
person or not and the final part of the
funnel is closing making the offer and
getting the offer accepted I'm going to
start by talking through some strategies
for building the top of your hiring
funnel these are the five places I'd
recommend that you look for making
engineering hiring for making engineer
hires I'll talk through the pros and
cons of each of these they are personal
networks hiring marketplaces LinkedIn
github job boards and meetups I'll talk
about how you can
the most out of each of these and this
list is ranked or it's sorted in order
of where I think you should start out
focusing most of your attention and
energy down to where you focus the least
so we start with personal networks in my
opinion personal networks are the best
place to hire especially when you're
early and making your first few hires by
far and the reason is anytime you're
deciding if you want to hire someone
you're essentially asking yourself two
questions one does this person have the
skills that you that you need for them
to do the job and two can you personally
work effectively with this person when
you're a big company you can mostly
focus on answering just the first
question because they're your large
enough there's enough people there's
enough teams that it's likely that
someone one team somewhere will be able
to work effectively with anyone but when
you're small that's not true whether you
can work effectively with someone or not
is a big determinant of your success and
if you hire the wrong person early on
that could literally be fatal so when
you hire someone that you've worked with
previously or you hire someone that's
worked with the person you trust you do
risk the chances that you won't be able
to work well together which is a big
thing to consider early on so that
probably sounds like somewhat obvious
advice and yet I'm surprised by how
often founders still don't really use
their personal networks effectively when
they're hiring and I think there's two
reasons for this the first is they don't
use a process to exhaustively search
through everyone that could potentially
hire and the second is they don't
actually make the ask that's usually
comes down to being afraid of being
rejected by your friends it's somewhat
easier actually to be rejected by a
complete stranger than it is to ask your
best friend to come join you and they
say I'm not sure the idea is that great
there's there's also like you can also
worry about what happens to the
friendship of the startup doesn't work
out like it's the sort of more that goes
into it when you're talking someone you
know personally that when you're talking
to someone you don't but the truth is
you just have to sort of suck it up and
do it
but you won your startup to be
successful hiring from people you know
it's a tremendously valuable resource
and you just have to make that ask so
I'd recommend you follow a strict
process here
start with just making a list of every
good engineer you know whether you think
they're available or not like that's
actually irrelevant doesn't matter if
they just sold their company for a
billion dollars put them on the list
then ping each and every one person on
that list to meet up and commit to
asking them if they would join if you
have a crazy you think it is however
unlikely commit to making the ask if
they say no they're hesitant so
deviously a little B and say will you at
least come by the office and see what
we're working on and if the office is
your apartment that's totally fine to
you but just keeps pushing until you've
at least shown them something that
you've done keep working on convincing
them if it doesn't work out if they say
no and you get a definitive no thence
then ask them if they were in your
position who would they try and hire
make a list and go out and repeat this
exact same process with them and this
process just never ends like I know
public company startup founders know
long startups pod like probably company
founders who kids still do this on a
daily basis like this is just like a key
thing you have to embed in yourself as a
start-up founder as your company does
scale and grow and the tea and you start
putting two team together you want to
start tapping into the personal networks
of your team and the way I'd recommend
doing this is team events where people
brainstorm potential hires and this is
commonly referred to as a sourcing party
the way I had to recommend going about
this is get everyone together send out a
shared spreadsheet and describe the role
that you're hiring for so if it's an
engineering role sort of described in
detail like who you're looking for who
are examples candidates what are skills
and qualities you're you'd be excited
about and then literally have everyone
spend 30 to 45 minutes going through
their LinkedIn or their Facebook or
whatever right there and then thinking
of everyone that could be a fit and
putting them into the spreadsheet
once that's done a trilobite I'll
actually then personally follow up with
anyone on that list who seems like a
good candidate or not and we've made
several really great hires doing this it
works works really really well and you
can kind of make it like a fun thing to
write so we'll do it at the end of the
week just before our Friday all-hands
food and drink and you can also offer
referral bonuses to your team to
incentivize them to do this so
really make sure that you use the great
you're sticking to an exhaustive process
you're making the ask of people you know
and then as you scale tap into the
personal networks of your team once you
sure that you've exhausted your personal
network for leads the next place I'd
start looking would be hiring
marketplaces hiring marketplaces are
actually relatively new they've become
more popular over the last few years as
has become harder to hire engineers by
using traditional methods like reaching
out on LinkedIn or github and I'm gonna
talk more about that next the way I
think about hiring marketplaces is
actually work a lot like dating sites
the idea is there's engineers who create
profiles companies that create profiles
and both are advertising their best
selves you message each other and you
figure out if it's worth meet up in
person and you know if it all works out
you make a hire the dynamics the
marketplaces those such that the demand
for good engineering talent far exceeds
supply and so typically it's the
companies that are being a lot more
proactive in terms of reaching out first
to the candidates the candidates are
getting multiple of inquiries and the
candidates or the engineers are the ones
that are choosing who they want to speak
to and who they don't a big benefit of
using a marketplace especially in the
early stages is that they can help you
hire very quickly because everyone most
candidates are on the marketplaces are
actively looking for a place to move
right now it's very quick to get on a
phone call with them and start pitching
and if you run a good closing process
you can significantly reduce the amount
of time you'll spend as a founder on
hiring which is obviously great the
downsides though are that they tend to
be quite competitive so engineers are
being reached out to do by multiple
companies at the same time so you'll
have to be very effective at convince
them to join if you want to make hires
and the second is that they can be
expensive so most marketplaces will work
on a fee per hire basis which can be 15
to 20 percent of the first year salary
that's cheaper than a recruiting agency
but still a significant cost if you're
in early-stage startup I'm obviously
biased Aircast requires a hiring
marketplace but I'd say like the three
main ones that come up in conversation
at least when we're pitching customers
we
be trilobite higher than Vetri you
should try they're all free to use to
get started so you're welcome to try I'd
say provide the way we differentiate
ourselves is essentially by having
better candidates and we measure that by
what percentage of candidates that
companies interview through to provide
do they make an offer to you and that
tends to be twice the rate that they
make through other sources and just as a
general note hiring as a funnel you're
optimizing your funnel so you should pay
attention to what percentage of
candidates are making it through each
step in your funnel when you're early
you won't have that many candidates so
you can't be that scientific about it
but start sort of capturing that data
and just building that into the habits
you have when you're thinking about
hiring the third source that I recommend
you go to and Mehcad is LinkedIn and
github and these are effectively the
biggest online directory of engineers in
the world and most of hiring that's done
at big companies is through teams of
technical recruiters reaching out to
engineers on LinkedIn or github finding
the ones that fit sort of certain
keyword criteria and sudden cold
messages the reason they and they go for
a very high volume approach here so
technical Kreutzer may well sound over
100 messages a day just in the hope that
they get a few replies and a dynamic
that occurred especially over the last
few years is there's more technical
recruiters there's more messages going
out on these platforms so response rates
are dropping for everyone which means
for early-stage startups in particular
it's going to require a lot of your time
sending a lot of messages in order to
get a few interested candidates so
making this work for you requires in my
opinion not playing to a high volume
approach like a big company recruiting
team word and instead spending the time
actually researching the reading the
details of profiles or reading through
someone's Linkedin looking through their
github looking at the details of the
work that they've done and sending a
smaller number of personalized targeted
messages and emphasizing when you send
the message why would someone be a good
fit for your company specifically and
give them clear evidence that you've
read their profile and you're interested
in them as an individual as opposed to
sending a spam message
but that doesn't mean the message has to
be super long I still advise keeping it
short and concise just the key fact is
there's proof that you've read their
profile final note here send emails
instead of messages so if you sign up
for LinkedIn recruiter light which is
about $120 a month that will give you
access to connect to fire it's a chrome
plug-in that makes it really easy to
pull out email addresses from anyone's
LinkedIn profile and you'll consistently
see much higher response rates through
emails and you want messages so
definitely definitely go for that okay
the fourth place I try looking for
engineers would be job postings or job
boards these the two main ones for
startup so stack overflow
jobs and AngelList I haven't included I
can use jobs on there because it's only
available to YC companies but how can
use jobs is somewhat unique and just it
has a particularly high quality of
engineer and I rank it second on this
list actually if it were sort of
stand-alone source of Engineers job
board in general do suffer from a
quantity of a quality problem so what's
good about them is you don't have to
spend a huge amount of time posting to
one of them the downside though is that
the time suck can come in later because
most of the applicants you'll get will
be vastly under qualified and you'll get
a lot of applications from people who
aren't even really software engineers
and it will take a lot of your time
reading through all of these resumes and
applications to find the one or two good
applicants so to maximize your return
and maximize the number of good
applicants you do get I'd recommend
focusing on making your job listings
unique and interesting and bear in mind
that the majority of job descriptions on
the internet are written by someone in a
recruiting or marketing department
that's using corporate boilerplate
language that isn't going to especially
using an appeal to an engineering
audience right so as a start-up founder
you can serve experiment to try and
bring through a bit of your personality
in the job listing so one thing you
might try is writing the first person
about the personal story for why you
started the company why you're excited
about the mission and making it seem
like you get that sort of excitement and
passion across other things you could
try is there anything unique about the
culture is there anything
specific about the technical challenges
or product challenges you're facing so
if you put in more details that again
will stand out because big companies
tend to be very generic and vague when
they're talking about what you actually
get to work on they're the final source
I talk about is actually just like
physically in person meet ups so I don't
think that these are actually going to
be very effective and they're sort of a
long shot like I just the numbers don't
really work out like in-person meetups
don't have that large of a number of
people in attendance and truth is most
of the time people are there for free
food and drink more than trying to
actively find somewhere to work so it's
unlikely that you're gonna find both a
really qualified candidate who's
actively looking to move who's excited
about your company and you also
personally need to be very effective at
talking to strangers and convincing them
of things it all for this to work at all
right so I've accrued it on there
because I do know startup founders who
have had success through meetups but
they are few and far between if you do
try this approach I'd recommend focusing
on technical meetups and by that I mean
the local closure programming group
where people come together and meet up
and bring laptops and work on things is
more likely a better source of engineers
than going to Dreamforce the final thing
you could try here is hosting meetups at
your own your own office right so you
could also combine this with the
personal network hiring and use as an
excuse to have friends come by the
office or have their friends who are
engineers come by the office at a
Tribble bite for example one of our
engineers is a fanatical Emacs user and
he hosts the Bay Area Emacs meets up at
our office and it's sort of a it's a it
hasn't worked for us for hiring but it
is a good way to just meet and build a
network of good engineers that could
come invaluable at some point in the
future so it's worth the definite worth
considering okay now I'm going to talk
about when you should think about using
recruiters truth is there's there's not
really any hard rule on when you should
hire a technical recruiter I've seen
companies of less than ten people hire
one I've seen companies wait until
they're 50 people on plus it's sort of I
treat these are my opinions or when you
should and I treat these as a rule of
thumb right so first I think you
absolutely should wait until you've at
least
you're first engineer before you
consider bring you on a recruiter in any
capacity the reason for that is actually
I think general startup advice applies
here so one is just in general when
you're hiring it's good for you to do
the job yourself for a bit so you feel
the pain and you understand it and you
sort of understand the details of what
makes someone good at that role at your
startup in particular before you go and
hire someone you'll be better able to
assess them so if you feel the pain of
recruiting yourself I think you have a
better shot of hiring the right
recruiter for you and the second the
second reason I say is just it's it's
like sales like it's actually good for
you to go out and try and pitch and
convince people to join your startup so
you can just understand yourself like
what message works and what doesn't
because as a startup founder you are
always selling and you never know when
you might bump into someone who could be
a really great hire and if you've
already sort of practiced the pitch for
convincing engineers to join you and
you'll have those ready to go so I'd
recommend making sure you always make
your first hire before you try and
delegate this to a technical recruiter
second I'd expect to have a good hiring
cadence so somewhere around hiring an
engineer a month for the next six months
or so and before you start bringing on a
recruiter otherwise it's likely they'll
run out of work to do a quickly and then
finally as a rule firm if you're
spending more than 50% of your time
sourcing that's like all the things I
mentioned before and doing initial phone
calls and screens and getting people to
come and meet you in person over 50
percent is probably about the time where
you want to start thinking about
bringing on help because 50% is about
the amount of time you want to be
spending on hiring so recruiters
themselves come in roughly three types
you have contract recruiters who you pay
by the hour and they can do anything
from just : messaging on LinkedIn all
the way to doing initial phone screens
this in-house recruiters it's just
hiring a full time technical recruiter
and that works as a member of your team
and the final would be agency and
agencies are essentially teams of
salespeople that are paying lots of
engineers on LinkedIn or wherever they
can
and then sending their resumes out to as
many companies as they as possible and
they tend to charge 25 to 30 percent or
first year salary if you hire an
engineers
maybe they sent you they do tend to be
fairly high touch so they're quite
involved in trying to give you
information that will help you close an
engineer but they're also sending that
information to multiple companies at the
same time so my recommendations here
would be when you get to the point where
you feel it's time to bring on help or
bring on a recruiter start with a
contract recruiter and have them focus
on just the sourcing piece of it so have
them just focus on reaching out to
engineers on LinkedIn and github and
their main deliverable for you should be
filling your calendar with calls with
promising candidates then you're doing
the pitching and practicing or yielding
the pitching and convincing when you get
to a point where that becomes too much
work for just you then I'd consider
hiring a full-time in-house recruiter
and training them to do the pitch cool
so now they're both sourcing and doing
the initial calls and sort of setting up
the on-site interview process for you so
to sum up most of startup hiring plan if
I were just getting going and building
an engineering team would be start by
making sure you've exhausted your
personal Network spend lots of time
taking people out for lunch coffee
making the ask to you experiment with
the hiring marketplaces your mileage
will vary on these depending on how
effectively you can pitch your company
but even if you don't make hires from
them you'll get valuable experience
pitching real engineers and real
candidates and learning what resonates
about your company to that audience
third spend some amount of time doing
personalized and targeted outreach to
engineers on LinkedIn and github making
those messages really personalized and
finally treat job boards and meetups
into meeting people in person as a
background process you run where you're
not expecting to make any highs from
them but you're sort of building a
general pipeline that could be valuable
in the future cool that's the first part
of this almonds are now going to talk
about how to screen and evaluate a
technical school of engineers then I'll
jump back in a wrap-up with making
offers and closing
awesome thank you hard so I'm Aiman I'm
hard as co-founder of a triple byte and
before this I started Socialcam with
Michael Seibel and I was an early
employee at twitch and I'm gonna talk
about just the screening step so how to
identify skilled engineers at your
company so the first question here is
just you know why you should believe me
about any of this and one answer is that
I've done a lot of interviews so since
starting trilobite I've interviewed over
a thousand engineers personally I but I
think a better answer is that you know
trilobite has a pretty special vantage
point we're able to you know see how the
views do see how candidates rather do
you know in the interviews at multiple
different companies are we can see how
the same candidate performs in multiple
companies and that gives us a data set
that I think no one else has and you
know that data is is you know where the
advice I'm gonna give today comes from
before I jump in I want to just go over
the the basic hiring process that most
companies use and this is actually
pretty standardized so probably 95% of
tech companies use these basic steps to
screen campaigns so first is a resume
screen someone applies to a company they
send in a resume any recruiter looks
over the resume and decides if this
looks like someone who's a basically
good fit then a recruiter call so this
is a usually a 30-minute phone call with
the recruiter I just ask about the
candidate background judge culture fit
and make sure they're interested in the
company then a technical phone screen
and so this would be between 30 minutes
and an hour with an engineer usually
solving a single programming problem so
this is sometimes something like
fizzbuzz or a little bit harder often
this point done over over a synchronized
text pad of some sort then this is
optional sometimes I take home project
so a substantial project
the candidate completes on their own
time and then you know sends in to the
company to be evaluated then finally the
on-site interview so it can they comes
into the office and does between three
and six one-hour sessions with engineers
at the company I you know covering
covering individual problems and then
finally a decision meeting so you so
usually the next day after the candidate
has gone home everyone who interviewed
the candidate and the hiring manager
gets together in a room and talks about
sort of their perceptions and make you
know they they as a group make a hire no
hire decision some stats on this
companies make offers to between two and
eight percent of all of the engineers
who apply but interestingly exactly
where in the process that drop-off
happens is is very different between
companies so we so we see companies
where you know seven five percent of
people who apply get screened out you
know at the first step on a culture fit
call and then we see companies where
almost all applicants make it through to
the final interview and that's where all
this reading happens and about ninety
five percent of people who are hired
work out that is about five percent of
technical hires result in someone being
being fired within a few months and then
from the candidates side what we see is
a distribution of success in interviews
so the the the top you know few
percentage points of programmers by
skill receive job offers after most of
their interviews but then the bulk of
programmers are somewhere in the middle
where they receive you know the you know
they do interviews and they receive
offers after somewhere between you know
fifteen to thirty percent of the
interviewers they do and an interesting
point is that no one passes all their
interviews so there are not magical
engineers who receive offers after every
interview they do and yeah this gets at
what I think is the the the major
challenge when designing any of you
process and this is inconsistency so
this is noise in the interview process
it's kind of the idea you know is your
interview fundamentally repeatable and
meaningful
you know if you had to if you could
somehow you know reading to view your
co-workers your employees or everyone
you who passed review in the last year
if you could be any of those people how
many of them would pass again and it's a
pretty scary question but kind of
interesting thing is that we've able to
add some data on this that's what I did
was I calculated a stat called the
inter-rater reliability between all of
the interviewers at all of the companies
on trilobite and so what that means is
this this is the statistical measure of
the extent to which different
interviewers tend to agree about which
candidates are best and it's on a scale
of zero to one where zero would be no
agreement or the amount of agreement you
would expect to see you know in random
data from chance alone and one would be
perfect agreement and what I found was
an agreement of just over 0.1 so so the
first point is that that's obviously
much closer to to no agreement than it
is to perfect agreement but for some
context than that I calculated the same
stat on a data set of online movie
reviews and what I got was a agreement
of very similar but it's actually
slightly higher so it ends up that you
know interviewers agree about which
engineers are the best at about the same
rate that Netflix viewers agree about
which movies are best and that's yeah
that's scary I interviews are
fundamentally noisy and they are they
are more noisy than the data shows them
to be more noisy than most hiring
managers sort of want to believe so I
know the first the first question here
is sort of why do invested all that
infinitives are noisy why do them at all
why can't we just use something like
trial periods
atashi engineers and yeah I think this
is actually a great idea it is almost
certainly much more you know if you can
work with someone for a week you can
almost certainly get a much
sense of if they're a good employee then
and then you could in in a you know if
we are interview with them the problem
is that most engineers don't actually
want to do trial periods so we did some
research on their sexual bite and it
ends up that only 20% of engineers are
willing to to do trial periods and
there's actually some there's some
adverse selection there so the you know
most of the best programmers are in the
80% who would prefer to do a standard
technical interview because it takes
less their time and is faster so I think
that trial employment is an excellent
option and you can offer that as an
option but you know if you don't want to
scare away most good programmers you do
have to still run a standard traditional
interview process so we're gonna talk
about sort of today is you know specific
pieces of advice that you can use to try
to reduce the noise in a traditional
interview and I'm gonna go over seven
points so point one the first way to
reduce the noise in an interview is to
decide what skills matter for your
company there are a lot of different
ways that a programmer can be skilled so
you know someone for example can be very
productive or they can be you slow
careful write great tests and and make
sure they don't commit bugs you know
someone can be strong in math and
computer science or they could be you
know deep knowledge about the internals
of the Linux kernel and and you know
scheduling and real-time operating
systems or something and if you don't
decide as a founder which of those
skills matter for your company then your
interviewers are going to decide that
for you so they're going to come up with
questions that they asked you in the
interview process and they will fail
people who answer poorly on those
questions whether or not those are areas
that that that should matter for your
company and this is actually a major
source of noise in interviews every you
know engineer has this bias where they
think the things that they know the best
are the most important skills one could
know an absent specific direction from
above about what to look for they will
fail people for areas that are not
important for your company
so my
first piece of advice here is that you
should go through and ask yourself these
questions before you start hiring us the
first is I need to clarify these are
these are the axes along which we see
most disagreement between interviewers
the first question is you know do you
need sort of fast iterative programmers
or someone who's careful and rigorous do
you want to look hire someone who's
motivated by solving hard tech problems
or someone who is motivated by building
you know beautiful products for users I
important that someone comes in with
skill in a particular technology pick
your language say or can you hide you
want hire a smart person and let them
learn your tech stack on the job is
academic computer science or algorithm
ability something which is important for
you or is that an irrelevant skill and
then is there any other sort of specific
expertise that you need in people you're
hiring it's actually so you know it's
fine to answer both some of these
questions you don't have to specify only
a single profile of person you're hiring
the important thing is to decide what
matters even if that's multiple profiles
um that sets you up to design the rest
of your process and make sure that
you're not you know failing people for
being bad in relevant areas okay point
number two second way you can reduce
noise in interviews is to use structured
interviews so to define this a free-form
unstructured interview is an interview
where a new viewer gets in a room with a
candidate and they ask questions and
they follow their intuition they they
you know based on the answer the critic
a that gives they ask follow-ups and
they try to get a sense what the
candidate feels like if that person can
be a good fit at the company and at the
end to make a global yes/no I don't know
how a decision based on that Daddy
interview and that contrasts with a
structured interview where the
interviewer comes into the room with a
question which they're going to ask and
a defined criteria they're trying to
evaluate and the very interesting point
here is that everyone thinks that that
freeform interviewers feel better almost
all interviewers prefer freeform
interviews and they think they are more
accurate in many candidates if you ask
them actually say they prefer to be
entered in that way but the
things that this is completely opposite
to all of the available data on this
structure knickers are simply more
predictive they are better at predicting
success on the job and there's no excuse
not to use them we should all be using
structure interviews and so in the purse
exams what that means um the first thing
is that you have to hold the process
constant so the goal of an interview is
essentially to evaluate variants and
candidates and you know if you do not
hold the rest of your process constant
between candidates you're introducing
noise so there's simply no excuse for
not asking every candidate for the same
job the exact same set of questions I
think the reason this is not more common
is that the interviewers themselves tend
to find this boring and you know I can
say it suck it up like hey you like it
you have to do that so second point on
structure interview is that you want to
give your interviewers defined criteria
to evaluate so rather than putting in
the room and saying decide if this K
this person to be a good fit for the
company say we care about coding
productivity and you know knowledge of
back-end web systems and so your goal is
to ask this question the interview and
grade the candidate on coding pregnat
ivities and knowledge of back-end web
and there's actually some great research
on this it ends up that a lot of the
sort of worst biases that can come up in
interviews are made worse when the
interviewer is trying to make a global
decision so if something's making a
global - this person feel like a good
employee decision that's where things
like you know do they look like someone
got you in the past or you know their
race their gender that's what those
things come into play and interviewers
are much better at ignoring those
criteria ignoring those attributes when
they're given a defined criteria to
evaluate and then final point is that
you want a unified decision-making on
this and this applies posted to larger
companies but you want to make sure that
one person or one group of people is
involved of all the final decisions so
rather than viewing interviewers as
people making decisions view them as you
know people taking notes grading
candidates on criteria and that all
those notes and criteria go to a
centralized person or a centralized
group who makes the final decision and
the idea is just that again the goal is
consistency and it's far more easy to be
consistent if one person
making all the decisions point three for
how to reduce noise is that it's just
used better interview questions and so I
have some tips on that
the first is that you want to avoid
questions that require a leap of insight
from the candidate and rather you are
questions where there is a gradual sort
of ramp of steps that they can follow
that lead to a solution and this is the
general idea the rule of thumb I like is
that you can ask yourself can this
question be given away so if it's a
question that has a sort of a single
fact in the solution which a candidate
could know in advance and perhaps be
communicate them by a friend or by
anything they read in Glassdoor then
that means that it's probably a bad
question and the example of that is
there's a plastic question the question
is you know imagine you're staying at
the bottom of a flight of stairs and
every step you can either take a single
step up one stair or a double step up to
stairs you know how many unique paths
are there at the top of the flight of
stairs and you know it ends up the
solution of that is the Fibonacci
sequence
kind of strangely if someone knows that
obviously it's you know that's the
solution if they don't know it they may
well struggle then think about it and go
down some some rabbit hole and so that's
exactly what is the solution example of
a good question is you know can you
please implement the game Connect four
for me so there you know it's a series
of steps each one relatively
straightforward but that leads to a
solution and and there's nothing F
summons friend could tell them in ten
minutes which would give them no
massively unfair advantage you know in a
game Connect four so another idea here
this is the kind of related but you want
multi-step problems and there's tend to
lead to problems I don't have insight
but also candidates will often get stuck
in an interview even good candidates and
if your problem has multiple steps to it
you can you can get them a hint you can
help them out in one portion and it
still have enough left for them to go on
to do well and be themselves and
demonstrate skill whereas if your
problem is all in one one one one one
sort of nugget of difficulty if they
can't solve that you have to help them
at that point they basically failed or
done poorly on that section you want to
avoid specialized knowledge
so this is you know if your goal is to
assess general program ability you
probably want to ask questions that
evolve you know things like list and
hash tables and strings rather than
questions that evolve you know tries or
prefix trees you know this list of court
you know unless you've decided that you
really care about algorithm
you know structure knowledge and your
goal is to make sure that me knows about
tries in that case it's totally fine to
ask about them but if you're if you're
measuring something else if you if a try
the portion of the problem you know some
portion of your your people your your
candidates will be familiar with us
others well in that will introduce noise
so in general I think it's good to stick
with the sort of classic most basic CS
concepts another route you want you run
a budget about three times the amount of
time it takes you to solve a problem for
the candidate so if you come up with a
question and you solve it yourself it
takes you ten minutes that's probably a
good question for a 30 minute interview
session and the reason here is just that
it's it's far easier to be the
interviewer that is to be the candidate
it's far easier to ask the question and
we tend to downplay how hard the
questions actually are and we can
actually research on this we went
through all the questions we asked we
asked a terabyte and we looked which are
most correlated with candidates going on
to succeed and it ends up that the most
effective questions tend to be much
easier than what you know our intuition
going in was predicting so it ends up
that most interviewers think that you
know the optimal question is quite a bit
harder than the optimal question
actually is you wanna make sure that you
ask
four or more questions in an interview
they hear is that you know each
individual question carries a certain
amount of noise as the person seems
questioned before is it you know did
they have whatever they lucky answering
it if you ask more questions you'll get
a a more consistent signal out and then
finally just one one tip type of
question we like a lot a trilobite is a
question where we we give the candidate
a problem and then rather than wanting
them to devise a solution we tell them a
solution to the problem and then their
goal is to take that idea and implement
that in the code and so we give them an
algorithm and we see if they can
implement that algorithm rather than
require them to devise an algorithm
a fourth way to reduce noise is to
ignore credentials during your interview
so by credential I mean things like I
you know did someone study at a
well-known school or has someone worked
at a well-known company and I'm not
claiming that credentials are meeting
are meaningless credentials are
important right so the productivity case
the group of people who you know our ex
new colors are indeed better engineers
the group of people who have not worked
at Google I'm so it's totally you know
legitimate to take that fact into
account when when when deciding about
the hire or someone however it's not
relevant to their actual programming
skill so my advice here is to make sure
that you're not biased by the fact that
someone comes from Google when you are
narrowly evaluating the programming
skill so I recommend you hide that
credential from the interviewers and the
reason is we found that interviewers are
actually pretty biased by this if they
know someone has you know what were your
strong credentials they're more likely
to interpret the result of the coding
screen as in a positive fashion or this
person you know yeah they didn't know
that answer but I'm sure they you know
I'm sure there was a temporary slip-up
and so how do pencils from your
interviewers let them assess program
ability and then when making the final
decision in the decision meeting
consider credentials and also the
performance in the interview and yeah I
this will help you find the programmers
who are skilled and who lack traditional
credentials and those are the
undervalued people in the market and as
a start-up if you can you know get if
you're good at finding those people that
is a big advantage okay point five is
that you want to think about the false
negative rate in your interview so a
false negative is when someone fails
your interview who could have gone on to
do the job well and the opposite of
false positive is when you have someone
past if you hire someone who then goes
on to do poorly and probably be fired
and both false positives false negatives
are very costly so if you hire a bad
person if the fire of them that's
terrible it'll hums the morale for the
team and also also very expensive its
actual money big problem but you know if
you're a start-up and you're really
hungry you know you're held back but not
having
engineers if you pass up a person who
could have joined your team and couldn't
productive that's also very expensive
and I'm making a pretty subtle point
here but I think there's a bit of a
cognitive bias where false positives are
very we're very aware of them
we're very like we hire a bad person we
feel that pain for a month or a month
plus best-case and we've seen comes into
a bite they're generally they generally
are have too much faith that the folks
who fail their process must have been
bad engineers and couldn't have done the
job and that's empirically not the case
right if you watch you know as I said
earlier no engineer will pass all
interviews right so a significant
portion of people who fail interviews do
go on to be employed very productively
at other companies and so I just
recommend that that folks designing any
of you processes think about the false
negative rate and try to give that some
way in in in their calculations of
setting studying hiring bars um one of
my goals would apply to actually just
get to a point where you can actually
measure this rate because cuz no one
knows what it is no one knows what the
false negative rate on the interview is
because to measure that you have to just
hire people randomly and see how they
perform that's very expensive
my goal is to get to where we can do
that let's see okay point six is that
you want to genuinely calibrate on the
maximum skill that each candidate brings
rather than their average skill or their
minimum skill so someone comes in an
interview they're very strong in one
area or the weaker and others what
matters the most is what they were
strongest in everyone can look stupid
right everybody you know if you ask me
the right question I will definitely
look very stupid that's true for
everyone out there and so the problem is
that someone might go through an
interview and do very well on some
things that would be you know useful for
the company but look stupid on one
question and you know if that
interviewer gives a blocking know that
that person was stupid that's
interesting noise in the process perhaps
now again if someone does poorly in a
crack in the area that is important for
the job totally failed them but be open
to the fact that everyone does look
stupid sometimes and don't fail someone
just because they look stupid on one
portion of the interview okay a final
last point here is that you want to
think about the candidate experience
when designing an interview you know you
want to you know make sure that every
candidate who goes through
I likes you likes your company and this
is true for a few reasons one is just
you know if they enjoy the process they
have a higher probability of accepting
an offer you make and so this will help
in the closing step but a interesting
point is that it will also actually make
your screening itself more accurate
because stress has a big impact on
performance high percentage of
candidates get very stressed in
interviews and underperform their actual
peak ability and so some tips here to
help you do stress include just letting
everyone bring in their lap and work in
their own environment
you know what throw and throw but their
own language their own tools they will
be they will be able you're much more
productive much less stressed and then
coaching your interviewers in just some
soft skills so being friendly
providing breaks for the candidates and
you know when they are doing poorly on a
section training them and how to
intercede anyway which isn't too
stressful insulting to the candidate
rule of thumb here that comes from the
the old Jolan software blog is that you
you you want every candidate no matter
how they do to finish your interview
wishing that they had you know wanting
join your company you know even people
who fail your any very poorly you want
them to end your interview wanting to
join you being signs about the
opportunity and the final point I you
want to avoid hazing so this is this is
rare but results in some of the worst
horror stories of interviews this is
where you know I mean who takes on the
role of you know a ritual of acceptance
into a group you know think if this if
this happens it's terrible and as a
hiring manager you can just stay totally
away from that okay those are my points
um I want to emphasize that I'm not
saying that you should lower the bar for
who you hire I think if you follow this
advice you will get the more accurate
signal you can then set your barbecue
higher RF you want on that signal i but
you'll still be making at that point
better hires so just to summarize here i
recommend that the first step you follow
is to decide what skills matter for your
organization and make sure that you're
screening on things that you actually
care about and then design a structured
interview around those skills so come up
with ways to assess each skill
and stretch the criteria for the
interviewers so they are you know less
likely to be biased by by outside
factors then you want to use good
interview questions you know multiple
parts in the lives of insight you want
to hide credentials from the technical
interest because that interest is noise
in the process you want to think about
the false negative as well as the false
to positive cost in your interviewers
and you want to genuinely calibrate
around the maximum skill that each
candidate brings well doing all that you
want to try to provide a positive
experience for the candidate so those
are those are my my tips so far I think
this all applies to both big and small
companies so I'm gonna go over a few
points here that I think are specific to
let's say Series A and smaller companies
so one one point here is winning what if
your what if you're so small you don't
have the scale to standardize your
process so your seed stage start off
your hiring your interviewing your first
few people you obviously can't run an
extremely standardized process because
the first two candidates have seen those
questions that's a totally real point I
think it still is worth trying to run
instruction interviews so you know you
won't have you'll still you know your
play-doh pie you simply Google Doc with
some tips tips written down but it still
is helpful to think about what skills
matter and try to design questions that
assess those skills that will still
reduce you know the bad bias in the
interview let's say that you're in
trouble sourcing so you're already
staged start up and your number one
problem is we know how do you get enough
qualified applicants for your company so
in that scenario it's fairly obvious
that a false negative costs more so if
you're struggling to get people to apply
to your company screening out someone
who's bad stress all right so here
someone who could have been good is a
very expensive more expensive than for a
large company but the flipside is that
if you're a small company hiring a bad
person is also way more cost you know
from the way more expensive so it's not
cream if the ratio of those two costs
changes so I think you still have to
care a lot about both I think what you
can do is be less aggressive about
screen folks out early so if you're an
early stage companies struggling to
source candidates I recommend you are
less aggressive in speeding out
you're on site you know pass more folks
through and accept a lower final
interview you know success rate in
exchange for you know better screening
all the applicants let's say that you're
a small start-up in use don't know what
skills matter so you're not sure if you
if you want hire someone who's you know
very CCS focus or someone who's very you
know web focused and there's no crisp
answer here so we have plenty of
examples of you know billion-dollar
companies that have taken various routes
here my personal advice from from
trilobite and from Socialcam and from
twitch when it was small is that yeah I
believe strongly that that that that the
two most important skills for the first
few hires are productivity and ownership
so being able to basically take a
project figure out has to be built and
just make that happen and I recommend
applies for that at the expense
potentially of code quality so I think
the first few hires at a company you
should accept that perhaps the writing
crappy code but you know by god they're
writing it quickly and they're getting
stuff done and I yeah just say that was
the case during the early stages of you
know all through comes I've been
involved with and I think that's normal
and probably good so let's say that
you're hiring for an area where you do
yourself don't have technical expertise
so you're you're a web developer and
you're you need to hire an iOS engineer
what do you do so what enters you can
you sure you can use a stick neutral
byte I will help you do that
I you can call them friends did you any
before you if you have them but I think
a good point here is that a trick that
I've used in the past is to just ask and
asking this to explain things so your
web developer you ask the iOS engineer
question they give an answer
you have no idea if it's a good answer
or a bad answer what you can do is just
ask them to explain you say oh that's
interesting can you explain why that why
that's a good idea and for the most part
if someone truly is a skilled iOS
engineer they should be capable of
explaining their answer in terms out of
web screen flow much get to understand
it's not always the case sometimes
someone come along who's you know good
at assumption but the bad communicator
and that that might fail them but this
is a pretty good trick to hire outside
your area of expertise
okay that's basically I want to end act
with an ask for you guys so this is this
is a we've been developing an exercise
for interviewers that we use when
training new interviewers patrol bite
and I want to see if I get you guys to
try this and I sort of email me and let
me know how it goes because I'm curious
but this works more broadly and the idea
is that and you know interviewers tend
to sniffily underestimate how noisy
interviews are they they overestimate
their own ability to distinguish to
engineer some bad engineers and part of
becoming a better interviewer is to is
to sort of become a little more humble
and more aware of your limitations and
so this exercise is designed to sort of
highlight that and so what I want you to
do is to do a mock interview with one of
your co-workers so have one of your
co-workers interview you where they're
role-playing you know they're asking
questions they're the interviewer and
you're role-playing a candidate you're
giving answers and I want you to tell
them in advance that you're going to be
giving bad answers to some of the
questions you're gonna be roleplay I
can't think who makes mistakes and then
during the interview they ask questions
I want you to half the time go ahead and
give a bad answer
roleplay a poor answer to the question
and the other half the time giving your
best shot and actually try to answer the
best possible answer you know to that
question and then after the interview is
done do a debrief session where you know
your coworker goes through and sort of
goes over all the mistakes you made and
gives you feedback and what's great here
is that they don't know what answers
that you gave were intentionally bad and
what were you trying your best and if
they MIT look if they don't highlight
the mistake you made where you were
trying to make a mistake they're gonna
look a little bit bad so they're fully
incentivized to be completely honest and
rigorous when putting out what the flaws
they saw in the interview and though you
know the criticism they give will apply
both of the points where you're
intentionally making mistakes but also
to your attempts to give your best
possible answers this is being really
interesting we've been doing this a lot
a trilobite and it's great highlighting
how interviewers disagree so if you do
this with your critic or worker and you
do it a few times reverse roles you know
the result
is that you
all well you'll highlight your area so
you're both weak but you'll also
highlight a bunch of areas where you
have legitimately strong disagreements
about what constitutes the best answer
to it to it to a technical question
there will almost certainly be more
disagree more than you're expecting
going in yeah I found this super
insightful I'd love you guys could try
this and I email me let me know how it
goes awesome that's a thing for me
hardies gonna talk about closing and
then we'll both answer questions okay
I'm gonna wrap up here by going through
best practices and point to optimize
your chances of people actually
accepting the offers you make them okay
I have five main pieces of advice here
the first is just understand as a
start-up in particular speed is a huge
hiring advantage that you have over
bigger companies so through two of why
we work with startups and larger
companies and we ourselves are surprised
by how often a big company can take
weeks just to deliver the actual final
offer details and when someone's getting
to the end of their job search process
that's when there's most keen to just
make a decision and move on and know
what they're doing so as a start-up if
you're quick at every step in your
hiring process from the moment you have
the first contact through to when you
make the offer you increase your chances
of closing a candidate so just be fast
responsive at every step
second Almond already mentioned like
train your interviewers to have a good
bedside manner with interviewees and so
we ask candidates or engineers on
trigger by what were some of the the
reasons you had bad experiences when you
went and interviewed in person at
companies and all of the reply centered
around their experience with the
interviewers and the top two complaints
were interviewers not being familiar
with the technical questions they were
asking and second the interviewer being
determined to show how smart they were
specifically smarter than the
interviewee so if someone has a bad
experience interviewing with you they
are highly unlikely to accept your offer
three be prepared to talk in some detail
about your company culture because
almost every candidate is going to ask
you that question what I like to work
here what's your company a culture like
and I think we've seen a particular
uptick in this question
over the past year anything frankly a
lot of stuff around
uber and just a lot of the focus on the
culture in the technology industry in
Silicon Valley is making people
especially individuals think more about
the kind of culture they want to work in
so two specific bits of advice here I
definitely be prepared to answer
questions about how you think about
diversity if your teams already diverse
or not I think you should have some
thought around how you plan on
incorporating that into your hiring
practices going forward and second when
you're describing your culture
be aware that almost every company like
a significant majority essentially use
three adjectives I open transparent and
collaborative and we've seen this on
trim why because we see them carrying
their profiles right and so that can be
an effective strategy because those all
three of those things are good
aspirational qualities right like no one
would not want to work at an open
transparent collaborative place and but
it's not very good for differentiating
yourself right so one strategy you could
take when you're talking about your
culture is take more risk and the
example the risk might be talk about the
trade-offs in your culture so if you are
if you believe yourself to be an open
culture talk about the trade-off there
right like openness means like being
honest about things and being honest
about things can be difficult and
uncomfortable for people so if you're
willing to kind of go in that direction
you may a lien ate some candidates but
you may also really increase your
closing rate on the candidates are most
excited about you forth get your team
and investors involved in the process so
once you made an offer make sure your
team reaches out afterwards offers to
meet up with the candidate again answer
more questions and generally be involved
in their decision making process and do
the same with investors and in
particular pick any investors you have
who would be particularly good at
closing that candidate so if they're on
the fence about whether to leave a big
company for your startup do you have an
investor that successfully left a big
company and joined a successful startup
and finally present full and transparent
offers with all the details the
candidate needs to understand how much
they're being compensated
this sounds against probably somewhat
obvious but I've been surprised by
seeing
companies engage in this sort of
hypothetical battle where instead of
just telling in candidate here's how
much salary and equity you get so posing
questions like how excited are you about
us if we made you an offer do you think
you join and this always creates a bad
awkward candidate experience it's also
unfair because the truth is no matter
how powerful you powerful your mission
is compensation is a big factor in where
someone's going to work and so asking
them to commit before giving them
details it just puts them in an
uncomfortable position and decreases the
chances that they would accept your
offer to join so when you do make the
offer provide full details this slide
has I take the minimum of what you
should put on an offer letter salary is
fairly self-explanatory with equity make
sure that when you present the details
of an equity offer so the number of
stock options exercise price etc that
you're also checking into a Sikandar how
comfortable are they with this right if
they're if they're a senior engineer and
they've worked at 6 or 7 different
startups they probably understand this
you don't have to go into too much
detail if they've spent most of their
life working at Intel they may not be
familiar with how startup equity works
right so ask them how comfortable they
are don't overwhelm them when you
present the offer details if they're not
just send them follow-up resources and
that they can read on their own time and
also this sounds somewhat obvious but
make sure you yourself as founders
really understand how stock options work
because people will ask you questions
about it and you actually don't end up
spending much time on this because you
yourself have restricted stock and
fundraising doesn't usually include
options but you should understand even
down to level all I'd say tax
implications of different types of
options a final thing I'm doing close on
here is a common thing that comes up
with startups is how do you compete for
engineers against the tech giants like
Google and Facebook in particular right
so Google and Facebook obviously can
offer much larger liquid compensation
packages than a start-up can and frankly
like the public tech company stocks have
been doing great over the last few years
so it's becoming more challenging to
compete against them still we routinely
see startups do it and win out against
much larger companies offering more
money
think there are four pictures they make
that have been quite compelling first is
emphasized learning the the case I'd
make here is that you learn the most or
you learn the fastest when you're given
real decision-making it's a
responsibility which means if you make a
mistake like bad [ __ ] happens and
there's very very little chance
practically no chance that that's going
to happen to a big company right like
big companies have checks and balances
in place to make sure that no one can
create too much damage in particular for
new hires right so if you tell someone
that hey like we just don't have that
luxury we're growing quickly we've got
to get everything shipped yesterday
you're gonna get thrown straight into
making a real decision making authority
and if you screw up that's going to be
bad for the company and that's the way
that you learn and build real experience
so emphasize that too I talked about
career progression and one bottom two
macro comment I'd make is if you look at
executives at public technology
companies they tend to be you're often
can be much younger than you see at the
counterparts that like public deactive
or like a public utilities company right
and the the reason for that is you can
grow up and be like chief product
officer Facebook at 38 or however old
the chief product officer is because you
join the startup when it was really
early and you grew along with it right
and the tech industry is really the only
place that happens like it's more of a
meritocracy you don't have to pay your
20 years dues at a company before they
consider you for a senior role you can
rise up as quickly as a start-up grows
so emphasize that third talk about
opportunity cost and in particular the
way I'd frame this or talk about this
would be at any given moment in time
there's always going to be a basket of
big safe technology companies to go work
at the names might change sort of every
five years or so but the experience of
working at one is largely fungible
whereas the experience of working at a
start-up varies wildly right so I would
emphasize the fact that your startup
right now the team you have the
opportunity is a unique one that's a
uniquely good fit for that candidate and
that they won't get again and if it
doesn't work out they can always go back
to generic big company
and final point this one specific to
hiring more junior candidates talk about
mentorship so one thing that we see is
especially for new grads people started
off college is that they're worried they
won't get the right level of mentorship
they won't learn how to best practices
work if they join a start-up and maybe
they should go work at Google for a
couple of years get that under their
belt and then join a startup I mean
first decide if that's actually true or
not right like if you're if you yourself
have only junior engineers on your team
and frankly you just own one to mentor
or get someone up to speed and then
don't make that case and maybe don't
hire someone like that and but if you
have experienced engineers on your team
emphasize that and emphasize the fact
that they will get to learn alongside
experienced engineers who have worked at
places and learn best practices etc etc
so that's everything I think we're gonna
open up for questions I will ask the
questions about the topics we've covered
you wanna come up like background things
are things that rule out the candidate
background background checks frankly
most startups I know don't do them
they're especially easy to do now though
because you can integrate Checker in
with your payroll service so sure but
that's not something I would like focus
on I focus more on like if someone can
be a good fit or not yeah
[Music]
that's a hard question so the majority
of computer science engineers are
probably not gonna be a to a pic Euler
good job of doing the work you want that
said this sounds like a case where you
could probably just evaluate past work
this person has done so you could
probably ask this person to take to give
you a portfolio or other examples of
work they've done and if that is at a
level and of a type that you're happy
with hiring them would probably work
yeah probably so the thing we focus on
is background blind hiring so we focus
very narrowly on just direct skills
assessment rather than looking at other
things that that correlate in our
predictive so you know personality type
is real people vary in their personality
so that stuff matters for performing
jobs I think it's more research on like
the big five rather than big five
percent of traits rather than - Briggs
all relevant but I would try to keep it
pretty separate from technical
assessment so it's assess technical
attributes yeah and then you know
separately try to assess you know
culture for it friendliness soft skills
and then combine that all and they try
to make a global decision yep sorry back
in the sunglasses
[Music]
that's the extreme version and I said
you probably can't so you okay so the
question is if you're a non-technical
founder how can you assess an applicant
technical skills and I think the answer
in fortune is that you probably can't so
you can fall back in the third device I
try to look at past work but I think
this is why it's very helpful to have a
technical co-founder is because you are
going to be at a fundamentalist
advantage there yeah I okay so the
question is how do you find a technical
co-founder and you figure out they're
good or not I think sort of Arlen's
advice basically applies here they the
most thing is the even if you use a
friend or some that you know who is an
engineer to talk to them and figure out
they're good engineer or not otherwise
there's there's not really any other
options yep yeah honey I'm not precise
with my pointing yes but I think this is
largely focused I'm sorry moving the
question the question the question is
other ways to work with the universities
and colleges to generate like a pipeline
of talent that you could hire from that
accurate I'd say yes there certainly are
on you know they exist like career fairs
and sponsored events at colleges et
cetera et cetera but I think those most
there's probably work better for larger
companies that can fit themselves around
the college graduation deadlines and
that schedule for start-up is kind of
tough because usually you want someone
that's available right now to hire as
opposed to waiting for them to graduate
so I probably wouldn't recommend
investing too much time in that as a
start-up and just to clarify big
companies at this point make offers a
full year in advance with large signing
bonuses you know you deliver it a year
in advance so it's very hard for
startups to compete with college hire
[Music]
yeah the question is to clarify unlike
my last point about role playing a bad
interview so the key point here is that
you're gonna roleplay need to do in the
cat you know the co-worker who's playing
the candidate who's getting the answers
they're going to intentionally make some
mistakes and what that does is it frees
up their coworker to be critical so
normally if you say if you do a mock
interview between two co-workers the
problem is that you know in the end
everyone's gonna pull their punches
they're not gonna honestly give their
opinion of the performance that that
their co-worker gave it just doesn't
quite work due to all kinds of social
pressure if you tell them I'm gonna be
intentionally making some bad I'm saying
I'm gonna tell you things and mistakes
that frees them up where they're taking
they're then free to point out the flaws
in your interview but only free to they
have to because if you say I'm making
mistakes and you ask them what's your
opinion of not even the results if they
don't point out a mistake you made that
means you got something past them right
so it flips the social pressure and
creates pressure where there then
incentivize to be critical which is
extremely useful because you know as
experienced engineers like weird like me
it's been a while your senior engineer
on a team after small company it's been
a while since you've had someone really
brutally critique how good you are at
answering your own questions and that
you know what will happen is that they
will point out legitimate flaws you'll
be trying to give your best answer and
they will point out things you said that
are wrong or things that could be better
and that it's very humbling it's very
humbling and I recommend that they do
that's I think this is exercise you can
give yourself that experience of being
humble and having flaws and even your
own performance pointed out in the
middle yes got it
you talked about a 95% plus success rate
on one of the slides and I have given
the the fact that the interviewers tend
not to have a very high rate of
reliability it seems time to believe
that there's a 95% and also doesn't
match my experience that 95% of the
hires successful so when you think is
the real success rate where you know
you're after hire something's still
there and they're pop before yep that's
gonna be so this comes from some so that
number I 5 comes from some surveys you
get upon companies okay sorry so the
question was I my slides I said that
that there is that tires are successful
ninety-five percent of time but that
doesn't mesh with you know the
experience of being a hiring manager
height people many hire are not not
great so the question is what's the
actual rate at which you know candidates
end up being top performers and yeah
questions totally right so that that
number comes from some surveys we did
where we asked companies of all their
hires what percentage got fired and we
actually asked web stands our top
performers and that five times the fire
rate so five percent actually get fired
you know an additional 30% are people
who stick on but are not particularly
great employees and then about 10
percent are in the bucket that cut that
companies said were there their best
hires and top performers thank you
[Applause]
you